if you're doing fall of the money work
you know with terrorist financing in
2010 to 12 Bitcoin was just an
unbelievable revelation we would talk
about it almost every day of what does
this mean like should we be tracking it
more like is it being used you know and
it's easy now in
2023 to like understand to look back on
it but in the moment we just had no idea
what was going to happen to it like it
was a tiny little thing today I would
say that Bitcoin is the most traceable
money in the world at the time it wasn't
clear like how the on-ramps and off
ramps would work and you know if it
would be traceable or not but looking
back like Bitcoin to me is the most
traceable money in the world but it's
also to me the best
money all right guys bang bang I've got
Sean here with me Sean I thought a great
place to start is uh you as a civilian
worked with DARPA and you both went to
Afghanistan for a number of months uh
you got guys were investigating Bitcoin
there's all kinds of different
technologies that very very early on
DARPA was uh interested in describe a
little bit like what is DARPA and how
did you get involved with that
organization oh that's a good one H how
much how much time we got for this one
as much time as you need all right this
is a crazy story um but so what is DARPA
DARPA is the research arm of the
Department of
Defense uh in the past the way DARPA
operated is kind of we'll set a vision
of there's some technology paino or
technology need and we'll then go create
a program and with that means is like
there'll be a program manager that for
example DARPA created the internet you
know it wasn't Al Gore it was it was
DARPA and the way that happened is
basically it's kind of realized by some
people at DARPA and other places that
there all these computers getting built
we had to network them together so that
you could share resources like share
printers which are really expensive at
the time uh and just have them talk to
each other DARPA doesn't build the
technology though historically DARPA
just comes up with the idea manages it
and has the money um and so like in the
case of arpanet which was the precursor
to the
internet came up with the idea um or at
least like manage the program and then
puts out what's called a solicitation
for proposals where hundreds of people
will apply hundreds of groups and then
the the program manager is kind of like
a DJ where you know they'll say hey I
think UCLA is the best at the networking
side of this and you know this other
group is best at like building the
firmware that would go on like a early
router and so and and the program
manager is also in charge of kind of
building in redundancy in case one group
doesn't perform and so they'll usually
choose call it they'll kind of break the
problem of say designing an early
internet and maybe four or five sub
pieces and chose like two to four groups
to build each of those uh but DARPA
created the internet stealth
technology uh kind of precursor to
GPS mr& vac seems are very controversial
these days but DARPA had a big role to
play in that um basically of giving
madna a bunch of money when it was kind
of an
Undiscovered company around 2012
on and on can list 50 plus Technologies
created by DARPA for myself I have a
very weird background in every way I'll
just I'll get this out of the table I
got an F in Algebra 2 in high school I'm
very proud of that it's one of my uh
proudest
accomplishments it's a good story but I
was just a weird kid I was hacking on
computers and building stuff just kind
of doing my own thing but a lot of my
family was actually in the military um
both both of my grandfathers served in
the
military my dad's dad all three of his
brothers served in the military two of
them died in World War II uh one of my
dad's Brothers was a career naval
officer when I was a kid he was a he was
a doctor and when I was a kid he was the
doctor that ran Pendleton Hospital you
know where like the seals train and so
my cousins lived on the base and then he
went and ran Walter Reed hospital or
Bethesda naval
that goes by two names and so like my
cousins lived on that base and so I
basically a lot of Americans grew up
with no exposure to the military I grew
up like if I wanted to see my cousins
who lived an hour away from us we would
drive down and go on the base and then
my mom's dad he was also a former Navy
guy and so he and I would go ride
bicycles around Pendleton and I it just
kind of a I had a lot of exposure and as
a kid
I I I actually really wanted to enlist
that was something that I I thought very
seriously about but with the F and
Algebra 2 and and kind of like a really
bad track
record at 18 um you know if if you
enlist and say the Navy and I mean my
goal would have been to try to become a
seal that was kind of my dream growing
up around Pendleton you know if you
don't make it if you wash out for
whatever reason if you have a even weird
things like if you have a heart
arhythmia that you didn't know about
then you kind of get put into the normal
enlisted ranks and you will have you
will struggle to find someone that's
worse at taking orders than me like I'm
I'm pretty good in chaotic unstructured
situations I'm absolutely horrible with
structure and you know I I'm embarrassed
I didn't have the self-confidence to you
know go do it and and like shoot my shot
but I was I was genuinely really nervous
about kind of not making it but so for
myself I I had from the time I was a kid
I had this like ambition to go serve my
country and and kind of be in the
military um but I I ended up despite the
F in Algebra 2 end up getting a PhD in
math and I mean technically it's in the
physics department but it started in the
math department and kind of while I was
doing my PhD I was at started at
Stanford and then I was at
Caltech uh
through a total fluke is like out of a
movie I met this woman her name is Rina
Dugan she she was the director of darp
at the time she's an unbelievable person
she's one of the people in the world
that means the most to me I haven't I
don't talk to her that much anymore but
Regina like you're you're the goat I
appreciate you and there was like a
Caltech lunch that she gave a talk at
there were probably 25 people in the
room a girl said something stupid it
kind of led to an awkward situation I
jumped in I kind of stood out for it at
the end she she was really busy in it
she stopped in the doorway and she said
if any of you want to get involved in
she stopped in the doorway but she
looked me right in the eye and she said
she said if any of you want to get
involved in a darer project find my
contact information online and get in
touch with me and you know I was like
was she talking to me like the director
DARPA and but I found her contact
information I sent her an email at like
9 9 p.m. that night we were I was
staying in like a little youth hostel in
DC she responded I mean I have the
emails but I think it was 4:44 in the
morning like she she's a beast and she
said yes I was talking to you um you
know what's your cell phone number I'm
going to call you
later she called me around 10:00
a.m. and she basically asked if I could
go to DARPA immediately and meet with a
few people um
I initially so I was supposed to fly to
Panama like like literally at 2:30 p.m.
or something it's 10: a.m. and I was in
Bethesda Maryland at the nah and she was
asking me to go to Arlington Virginia
for any of you that know DC geography
it's you know it's it's an hour away or
whatever and then I had to get to D
airport uh and it and if I didn't make
it I would miss my friend in
Panama um and for what is wor El
Salvador goes into that story if we want
to get there later but uh so went met
sorry I actually initially said no I I
can't make it hung up the phone a minute
later I just had this deep deep pit in
my stomach of I was closing the door on
like a truly once in a lifetime
opportunity I could just kind of hear
her voice deflate and she said that she
would have me do some phone calls with
people but I I just called her back I
just re redialed the number she picked
up I was like I'm on my way I'll be
there as fast as I can I got there H I
joined a very unique program it's like
basically something that DARPA hasn't
really ever done normally DARPA doesn't
build technology nor normally DARPA just
like builds technology for 20 years in
the future but she realized when she
came in she basically went and asked a
bunch of generals like people at the
Joint Chiefs is DARPA actually useful
and the reaction she got was DARPA is
useful 20 years in the future like DARPA
is useful for the next War but it's not
useful for the current Wars and at the
time you know things were still very
active in Afghanistan in particular um
and to her she felt like that was
unacceptable and so she decided to spin
up kind of a a live operational team
inside of DARPA that was actually
Building Technology you know like fast
fast prototyping based on needs or
gluing existing Technologies together
that could be deployed very rapidly um
and they were really like 10 of us that
were the
core kind of
Architects uh and drivers here and then
some people that helped support us but
part of this is we'd be rotating in and
out of Afghanistan because it's just
really hard to know what to build if
you're not actually on the ground and
seeing the gaps and what people need um
and so she recruited me for that program
I mean like within 3 hours
of meeting her in of meeting people at
DARPA I had a this is like I had an
early smartphone I didn't have an iPhone
yet this is in 2009 um and I got an
email like saying when could you be in
DC h i was s literally sitting on a
plane to Panama at the time at like 2:30
I made the flight um and I responded
like I'll be there in eight days because
I basically went to Panama met my friend
we this was like winter break during our
phds in 2009 and we this is my friend
Jeff Marlo shout out Jeff uh and we
basically rode buses from Panama City to
uh to Yucatan Peninsula so you know
through all the countries there
including through El Salvador and that
was just very fast for Crazy M massachus
so it was like call it one long bus ride
a day we made it through call it eight
countries in in eight days and then I
moved to DC with my back p and spent two
years living out of
backpack uh doing crazy obviously
there's a bunch of stuff that uh you
guys do that you can't talk about but um
when you're doing these rotations into
Afghanistan um it reminds me a lot of uh
maybe Elon Musk talking about hey the
engineers got to be right next to the
production line right the designers need
to be right next to the engineers like
there has to be that feedback loop and
understanding what's working what's not
working um and what your design
decisions actually have in terms of
implications what are some of the things
you guys would do on the ground to
actually get that feedback to really
understand uh what to build and maybe
what not to
build amazing question um I
mean it was the there's just no
substitute for talking to lots and lots
of people that are like actually just
coming back from combat and they have an
immediate memory of some problem or
paino or just literally moving around
the country
like uh I I kind of I mean I don't
remember exactly how many Blackhawk
flights I did while was there but
probably 30 you know in in three and a
half months I would just go kind of and
and like Road in cars around like seeing
stuff happening every day almost and
just the act
of um moving and talking to people it
just completely changed your perspective
I'll give you an incred L simple stupid
example um I had a I had a lot of data
sets one of the data sets was around IED
stuff um that's basically all I should
say but one of the variables in there
was like this was a massive data set and
one of the columns was called CT uh I
didn't know what a culvert was so I just
kind of ignored that like column
coverts are kind of like when you have
storm drainage under under Road whatever
it's like what the water flows through
and I'm very embarrassed that I didn't
maybe it's my uh my poor high school
education but I didn't know what that
was and it turns out it's incredibly
important for finding IEDs because you
don't have to dig up the road if there's
a culvert on you you know someone can
just crawl into the cul and put an IED
down there and you know if you're going
to try to if you're like sitting in DC
looking at a data set and you know
there's hundreds of columns in it it's
just sometimes hard and and this was
pretty deep learning and so uh still a
lot of this was like human intuition
based and we called it statistical
learning rather than you know these
blackbox neurl nets um and so things
like that so powerful but I mean another
example was uh I I
was basically I had kind of a schedule
where a couple days a week I would go
this one base to another base and that
was about an hour and a half Drive
normally it only maybe 5 miles but there
was insane traffic and it was I would do
it a few days a week and I would do it
every Friday normally it would take an
hour and a half um this one Friday we
got there in like 15 minutes there was
literally no car on the road it was
Eerie it was so scary and we get to the
base and and and the base was hqf it was
like the primary base for for the joint
command of kind of all the different
Allied Nations that were all the Allied
Western Nations that were deployed there
and right when we got there we went to
like all the Intel channels to try to
understand is there like do we is there
an attack coming or what's happening
and there wasn't any
clear like obviously there's always a
lot of noise but there wasn't anything
clear
and then a few hours later like a large
combined attack happened coordinated
attack you know across like multiple
bases you know Rockets into towers and
stuff and um it's just one of these
things where the context of like oh wow
when when somehow people knew and that
having no cars on the having like the
car traffic
decrease was clearly predictive that
something was going to happen and maybe
not 100% of the time but things like
that it's just if you're not there it's
hard to have the context that that's
relevant but when you're there it's just
the most obvious thing in the world you
know you have a routine and now you just
had this major break from your routine
um and so I mean I could give lots of
examples the best examples are you know
ones I can't talk about but I don't know
what's interesting about it is um it's
like the human intelligence right
obviously is incredibly powerful and and
um one of the things that over 20 years
you know of uh kind of dealing with
insurgencies and and these like forever
Wars um it seems like uh people on the
ground really started to understand that
you can have all the best technology in
the world you can have you know all of
the vehicles that can sustain uh you
know explosives you can uh do all sorts
of data analysis you can have the best
uh kind of trained teams literally the
difference between life and death could
be like does the guy on the street
corner like you enough to Simply tell
you don't go down that road
right and that happens all it's such a
good point like that happens all the
time I just want to call it one one
thing that I I gloss over part of part
of why I gave those examples is I was
working on this from 2010 to 2012
primarily and that was the very early
days of like big data it was the very
very very beginning and so we were
always we we kind of had a mandate to
work with any type of Technology but the
thing where we got the most leverage at
that moment in time
was kind of Big Data trying to take all
these data sets or sensor systems or
whatever that had never really been
analyzed and so that just that's why I
gave those examples um and you know and
the other thing I just want to say
is I hopefully from the Preamble around
like having a lot of family that served
uh it's not that I'm so special or
anything but there's something about
when you are deployed in uniform and you
have like a job and everyone else's life
depends on you doing that job very well
and you're working like 14 hours a day
in super stressful situation it's hard
for your mind to like go come up with
new ideas or sometimes even to like see
the patterns that are like should be
obvious but are just not obvious when
you're so stressed and so focused on a
single task and so we had this weird
mandate to just kind of go be observers
almost but like very very technical
observers that were aware of what
technologies existed and what was
possible and just kind of go be glue to
fit in there it's like it's I I I think
it was a it was literally a genius idea
of drct Dugan uh and and it really was
it was a life-changing thing for me
while you were at DARPA uh obviously
2010 to 2012 is right after Bitcoin is
created and kind of launched to the
world um I know that DARPA and a number
of other organizations pretty quickly
started to pay attention to this thing
um what what do you remember from that
time period of just like what were
people thinking internally uh were they
excited were they not and know there was
research going on around it just talk a
little bit as to uh kind of what that
experience was yeah I mean it was like
it was crazy to be at DARPA in the early
day to be at DARPA embedded in
Afghanistan during this time
because one of the core things we were
doing was with especially from the
perspective Big Data was a lot of follow
the money work um so like trying to
understand how money gets in and out of
the country trying to reverse engineer
the chain of shell companies and and
figure out like sources of where money
is coming from it was a it was a major
thing we were doing and you know I think
at least four or five things we did made
the front page of the New York Times uh
I'm very very proud of that um so like
we like we were actually successful at
this uh and if you're doing follow the
money work you know with terrorist
financing in 2010 to
12 Bitcoin was just like an
unbelievable revelation we would talk
about it almost every day of what does
this mean like should we be tracking it
more like is it being used you know and
uh it's easy now in
2023 to like understand to look back on
it but in the
moment we just had no idea what was
going to happen to it like it was a tiny
little thing um but it it was very
disruptive it wasn't now today I would
say that Bitcoin is the most traceable
money in the world at the time it wasn't
clear like how the on-ramps and
off-ramps would work and you know if it
would be traceable or not
um but looking back like Bitcoin to me
is the most traceable money in the world
but it's also to me the best money I I I
am a mega Bitcoin fan but it was just it
was truly a core part of what we were
doing and then leaving
DARPA immediately from there um myself
and two friends came up with we
basically decided to start a research
company that was doing DARPA research so
we we kind of were getting contracts
from DARPA to do AI research Big Data
research cyber security research
and about a year and a half later we
brought in another person who came up
with a really smart idea um that became
like our product which became the whole
business and in in like late
2013 that idea actually used Bitcoin
like we actually we were using Bitcoin
Bas it's kind of a long story but we
needed we needed to do computation that
no one would be able to trace back to us
and we were using Bitcoin to basically
pay like Estonian and uh some like
Baltic server companies to go kind of
run compute jobs for us which then would
get pushed on the internet and as crazy
as it sounds we actually needed to do
that back then and the the architecture
evolved beyond that after maybe six
months but anyways we were we were using
it and what was the idea in terms of
like what were you guys trying to do and
and I know that this business ended up
growing uh quite large and you guys
eventually uh were able to uh to sell it
but what was the original idea that you
guys said hey look let's turn this into
a product this episode is brought to you
by Aron
they are a brand new startup led by a
number of Silicon Valley Legends who
just raised $81 million to build the
future of Internet infrastructure you're
probably wondering what that means let
me explain there are numerous new
disruptive technologies that are being
adopted simultaneously from blockchain
to artificial intelligence to zero
knowledge Technologies in order to
ensure that these Technologies thrive in
this new world we need new
infrastructure and that is where arine
comes in they just launched their first
product line called Tera flux which is a
bit coin Miner powered by the world's
first 4 nanometer silicon chip
technology these air cooled singlephase
and dual phase emerging cooling miners
have unrivaled speed and efficiency
they've Superior uptime and they
leverage a brand new innovation called
Energy tune that allows miners to
dynamically adjust the energy
consumption and Bitcoin hash rate based
on demand response needs of the
electrical grids aradine is an ambitious
company working on hard problems I'm
really impressed with them and if you
want to check out more you you can go to
idine.com that's a r a d i ne.com go
check them out at idine.com today yeah
so the original idea was or the
observation was that if you go back to
2013 if you ask basically any company or
government agency what is your network
like give me a list of all of the
computer devices you own give me a list
of all of the
video cameras the servers the um you
know the like routers give me a list of
all of the devices that you own believe
it or not no one had those lists like no
one had a map of their own assets on the
internet and if you're going to defend
something like you need to have a map
before you can defend it I have so many
crazy examples of
uh I mean like servers that had been
running for 30 40 years that were like
put inside drywall that people still
like you know didn't know existed
anymore and so basically
we that was the Insight I I was not the
one that came up with that Insight one
of my co-founders did to give them
credit um but it it was such an obvious
insight to us once we had it based on
what we've been doing and so we decided
okay this is an super important problem
cyber security is going to be huge huge
like let's go solve this problem and so
now this is a kind of a category in
cyber security called attack surface
management is what it got named later on
and so the way we solved this kind of
the Insight that another co-founder had
um like one had the idea of what the
product should be the other had the idea
of how to build the technology and I
basically sold it and you know executed
on it and hired a lot of the team um but
my my co-founder kind of realiz realiz
that in 2012 we had just gotten to the
point where you
could use Big Data ideas and send
traffic send packets to literally every
single device on the internet like to
every single device and on a regular
Cadence like every hour or so and see
what responses you get back and like
through kind of what we call
fingerprinting you could figure out what
those devices were and so we started off
by building a superet of every single
device on the public internet if
something was behind a properly
configured firewall then or if it was on
a black list or white list of what we
weren't supposed to send packets to then
we wouldn't touch it but otherwise we
knew everything on the internet and then
from there we would try to figure out
from the superet of everything who owns
what you know just Goldman sax on this
does JP Morgan on this does the Navy on
this and and so we kind of would start
from the top and then
segment everything and part of why we
needed Bitcoin is uh we were sending so
much internet volume that if people knew
that all the packets were coming from us
like if we were sending from the
same server infrastructure then they
could just ban any packets from those
servers going to them and so we wanted
to have uh like server infrastructure
that wouldn't be traceable to us and
that we could kind of move around so
that people wouldn't realize that we
were kind of effectively like a very
light dos but kind of a
Dos how much you guys sld the company
for a billion dollars the and it's funny
the public the it was publicly reported
as a little less than that
um and it's kind of I don't even know
why but the acquir wanted to report it
as last so they didn't
include basically so it was it was a
billion 50 million 1.05 billion to the
cap table so like two investors or any
employees that were no longer there um
but they didn't include in the announced
number
like
the revest in equity for the people that
were continuing or um or not just revest
Equity just any Equity that been granted
but not yet fully vested and so that was
a discrepancy yeah it's um it's
interesting how they kind of think about
about that another thing is um you've uh
you've tweeted a bunch of times about uh
naib buelli down in El Salvador and um I
think that uh he obviously is
implementing a pretty radical plan uh
radical just being different right not
necessarily good or bad um the impact so
far or the results seem to be pretty
encouraging uh there's obviously some
people who have concerns about you know
kind of the style or or or the concerns
in terms of what uh could potentially be
used as abusive power but uh so far it
looks like he is drastically stomping
down on criminal activity he seems to be
cleaning up uh a lot of corruption and
then uh it looks like you know citizens
basically are headed towards a better
life right one that has more freedom
more Prosperity Etc what has been your
experience I you've gone to the country
a bunch of times and and seem to have
studied you know what he's doing what's
your read on what's going on there so I
I've been to ELO I think five times and
I've traveled it pretty extensively you
know like I've taken buses from the
south to the north I've been to the
volcanoes I've been to the beaches San
Salvador Etc um and I have a few friends
there that I kind of still get to check
in with and see how things are going and
it's it's weird the first time I went
there I I fell in love with the country
it was super dangerous I think the first
time I went was 2007 and it was super
dangerous at the
time um and when you would talk to I
mean like my friend had security at
their house like it was they were it was
you could feel Ms 13's presence um
and look I'm I've been really impressed
by B today like I've I've been blown
away by him today uh I think that he
inherited a horrendous situation I mean
you can go look at the murder rates in
the country 10 years ago compared to
today and it's kind of like he inherited
a trauma patient that had been shot like
four times and was bleeding out and he
had to take like really radical kind of
risky action to stabilize the patient
and I think he's done that masterfully
um there's still a question around the
future so I think he's done the
stabilization step incredibly well we
don't know exactly where it'll go in the
future um but so far what I've seen from
bu has been just like incredible Nuance
um
like huge
bravery uh willing to look stupid in the
short run to be Vindicated in the long
run which I think very few politicians
are willing to do these days so I I hope
that's actually an example for other
politicians that sometimes you know like
he looked really stupid when he bought
Bitcoin and the price went down uh but
now he has a 93% approval rating and um
you know he's just I've been really
impressed by him I've been very
impressed by his Nuance views on things
and kind
of the risk-taking and the ability to
try to engage the technology community
so I don't know where it'll go but I've
been really impressed so far when you
think about um a politician like that
how much do you think age plays into it
like obviously uh El Salvador seems to
be like the exact opposite of the United
States and and uh one of the things uh a
number of friends and I have been
talking about is just like uh no matter
how innovative want to be no matter how
um you know kind of uh uh refresh
thinking you want to be age does play a
role right and especially if you are
then not only yourself getting older but
then you're surrounded by older people
as well I think one thing that venture
capitalist figured out very early on is
like hang out with young people right
and like that's where the fresh ideas
are that's where kind of innovation
comes from um I I really don't know
right maybe politicians are spending
time with a bunch of young people it
doesn't strike me that way um but buelli
seems to be well obviously one he's
younger but also two is the average age
in some of these developing nations
tends to be younger as well and so do
you think that actually plays a huge
role or is that something that like we
want to kind of put it into a box and
explain it but but maybe isn't as
impactful as we would
think personally I think it plays a big
role um I you know the the Nuance view
though
is I think you kind of want all age
groups kind of all together I think that
we are today American politics is just
skewed way too old like the the median
age is probably 15 to 20 years to old
but you know the the thing
that old people bring is huge amounts of
experience and like the wisdom that
comes with that the thing that young
people bring is fresh eyes you know work
ethic
energy uh being closer to the
technology changes that are happening
you know and just like understanding the
voice of of a different cohort of people
because they're much closer to it so I I
just to me if I could wave a magic wand
and you know lower our American say
congresses or this yeah the house or the
Senate's median age by 15 to 20 years I
think that would be hugely impactful uh
but it's you know it's it's not to say
that we don't have some phenomenal you
know
elderly uh
politicians let's um let's talk SpaceX
uh obviously I think people are very
excited it's been you know 20 plus years
since the company was started um I think
that you've invested like a billion
dollars in the business um SpaceX is
known for Rockets starlink is becoming
uh a much bigger story uh they recently
announced direct to sell uh which is an
entire you know concept of like screw
the carriers screw everybody else like
we're just going to go straight from the
satellite to your cell phone
how do you think about that business and
like maybe what the potential outcomes
could be uh both in terms of size but
also importance in the world oh man I
SpaceX gets my my fire on I mean it's
just such an incredible company
and one of the I
mean I just want to call out from the
beginning you know one of the things
about getting to be a little bit close
to the company is you see the work ethic
of the team and man I mean part of the
beauty of having such an exciting
Mission that's so clearly stated and
that is in like for many people
existential you know like how I think a
lot of people do view going to Mars as a
kind of a a really important thing for
Humanity and it's just like the the work
ethic and sense of purpose in that
company is unreal I've never seen
anything like it and it and despite what
the media wants to say like it starts
from Elon like that guy is is
a he's a
it's incredible how hard he works you
know I'm 37 and I can't I I I couldn't
even come close to keeping up with the
number of hours he works it's it's
insane um and so I don't want to take
any credit for what the team is doing or
whatever I I'm very lucky to kind of get
to be a fly on the wall and make some
money from it but I don't want to take
any credit um for myself and for sequa
we've we haven't really talked about
this it's not a secret but yeah we've
invested about a billion dollars into
the company the largest investment was
in July
2020 so this was kind of when starlink
was like that you could demo do the
earliest demos of the constellation but
it's right before they had any Revenue
um and so kind of the we just we saw the
inflection that was going to come as
they were able to convert there's 20
years of potential energy you know of
building like this insane launch
platform and now start launching
secondary like very kind of
profitable Mass consumer businesses on
top of it um you know I some of the
things that I I think are just
unbelievable you know last year the
company put and elon's tweeted the
numbers something like 60 65% of all the
world's Mass to orbit like if you look
at all the Mass from every Space Program
globally that's both private and public
um including the Chinese space program
last year SpaceX was about 65% this year
it's going to be like 75 or 80% you know
in
2023 SpaceX has not had that many really
major inflection points in its history
um but the company's kind of right at
arguably the biggest in its history and
so even those numbers like 75 80% of the
world's Mass to orbit in three years
when Starship is like really really
working and it's just is flying you know
100 times a year I mean it's it's G the
numbers are going to be really crazy and
so you know the the things I would keep
in mind about the company are it took 20
years to kind
of build the system that can make the
system and to kind of get the company to
a very
stable Strong place and now we're just
at the very beginning of converting that
kind of stored up potential energy to
kinetic energy which would be seen as
like uh Revenue
profits just Mass scale activity you
know the
company's you know starlink obviously
still has lots of new markets to launch
into um
that I I I don't want to say anything
that they haven't shared like you know
they announced direct to sell two days
ago what that means is like the initial
thing is basically for any of their
Global cellular Partners so like
T-Mobile was one of the first in in the
US uh if you're a T-Mobile customer
you'll be able
to if you're I think I shouldn't go into
the exact details on like how the plans
work whatever but if you're T-Mobile
customer you'll be able to get star a
starlink add-on which will give you no
dead zones so like if you're hiking if
you're you know driving and there's a
dead zone it'll the the will just kind
of automatically spill over from the
T-Mobile network to space like literally
your cell service is going to come from
from space it's it's pretty sweet H it's
basically like having a uh a consumer
friendly sat phone or a satellite phone
is uh kind of the the sense that I get
in terms of what I was reading that's
true but
um look for me it's it's more just it's
more like sell Towers in space you know
if you in the past
part of why like
satellite internet and all that has a
bad reputation is in the past basically
all the satellites lived really far away
from Earth they you know they
lived I I think it's a factor of a
thousand higher orbit than than where
Starling satellites
live the round and the roundtrip time
for a signal to go to one of these
satellites in back was about a second
and so you have you know latency there's
a lot of loss of like the the kind of
the energy in the beam as it's as it's
going that long distance and so like the
total bandwidth that you can get to the
ground is not that great um with
starlink you
know people will rewrite history but
four or five years ago people didn't
think it was possible to like I when I
did diligence on the company almost
every expert I talked to said it's not
possible to have you know broadband
internet from space at a mass scale
where like lots of people can be using
it in really you know fully power rural
environments and have as much bandwith
as they need um here like I I think it's
the way I would think about it's really
like spoofing cell towers in space it's
really just kind of lifting lifting the
some of the ground infrastructure into
space and it's low enough you know on
the order of between 4600 kilometers
above the Earth that you know you're
just you're really not that far away as
crazy as that sounds like it's it's
really just it's almost right above us
yeah to to me I think that's what um
becomes really interesting is almost uh
elon's learning from Tesla of vertical
integration and you know a lot of people
I don't think really understand how many
of the parts they make in house and how
they've been able to simplify Supply
chains and just you know the more you
learn about it I think you're just like
wow that's really hard very complex but
obviously if you can pull it off it's
super successful it feels like almost in
in a weird way he is now vertically
integ grading uh hey if I can get things
into space what are all the use cases of
things that I could do up there and uh
starlink seems like a pretty good place
to start but uh I gotta guess that he is
considering you know what else could he
be doing um yeah they are I'm just you
know I don't I want to be sensitive to
you know I don't want to step on
anyone's toes but but I do want to say
my mental model for both Tesla and
SpaceX is they're like they're each 20
companies in one you know like for Tesla
they're obviously make cars first of all
the thing that I so I was negative on
Tesla like seven years ago uh and it was
just a stupid naive argument that all
the hedge fund people had which was oh
if you add up the market cap of all the
autom makers you know like Tesla's
doesn't even make anything yet and it's
already bigger the thing I got wrong is
I'm actually on the board of a li art
company called luminar that is selling
into the automotive industry um the
thing I didn't appreciate back then is
that the oems today like they don't make
that much they basically buy almost all
of their parts from a large supply chain
like for example there's a public
company called nxp that makes
semiconductors for cars you know there's
there's like a company in called there's
a company called aptive that does a lot
like the wire harnessing so they kind of
like harness up all the electric cables
you know a lot of that's manual and
there's just like there's all the sub
companies many of which are like large
companies um there's also the gas
stations like there's this whole thing A
lot of people are looking at just you
know the O today basically
just sell cars do the financing and like
a little bit of the design they don't
make many of the pieces Tesla is making
almost everything it's literally 20
companies in one they're making
semiconductors they're you know they're
making the batteries they're even GNA
like refine lithium you know they're
they have the gas stations through the
charging Network they have autonomous
vehicles they have like the software the
control systems for the cars you know
like it's just they they even have they
make like the speakers for the car you
know like which is the on and on and on
it's it's 20 plus companies that also
has all this potential upside through
things like self-driving things like
Optimus the robots that we're seeing and
so I just had the wrong mental model for
the company and Tesla and SpaceX is very
Sim to me you know like obviously the
rocket is the core thing that's that's
the Workhorse but to make the Rockets
there's so many different subcomponents
but even to make satellites like with
Starling you know they they make the
engines that power the satellites so
when satellites are live you know when
people talk about space debris um in the
orbits where starlings live you know
call it below 600 kilometers there's
actually still some atmosphere there's a
little bit of atmosphere up there and so
when these satellites are flying they're
actually colliding into you know
atmosphere molecules whether it's oxygen
or you know carbon dioxide or whatever
it is they're colliding molecules and
every time that the satellite collides
into one it slows it down a little bit
and that would cause it to start
descending to Earth you know it would
cause it to fall into Earth's gravity
well and ultimately burn up and so to
keep these things in orbit you know like
with space debris if you're below 600
kilometers or whatever where where
stlink lives if you if you turn off your
engine you will within a couple years
just fall into the atmosphere and burn
up including all the debris if if God
forbid one would break there was a
collision um but so for example like
they make these engines that power the
satellites and so there's just it's
they're making the phased array antennas
that um that like go into the Starling
user terminals so it's it's it's really
just unbelievable I think people have
the wrong mental model for just how
impressive these companies are how do
you guys at SEO or just yourself think
about some of these new technologies
right so obviously SpaceX and Tesla I
think have become these household names
obviously Elon uh very well known for
doing some of this stuff but you are
literally in the business of going and
finding the next spacex's the next
Teslas and so like what are the areas
that you're looking for how do you guys
think about you know trying to
underwrite like hey maybe there's
Innovation happening but like is it
going to be commercialized is there is
there actually a business opportunity
here or is it more of a research project
just talk through maybe some of the
things that you've learned over time and
and kind of what that process looks like
yeah so Sequoia is a partnership and
it's kind of this may sound crazy
but we the way I describe it
is it's a bunch of people that are
simultaneously like we're like we're
simultaneously a bunch of individuals
that are all very very different from
each other and have very different
investment Styles investment interests
but we're also like simultaneously an
incredible team that like really tries
to push each other's thinking and really
tries to work together and really tries
to help each other whenever it's needed
um and we've almost constructed our team
the way you would construct a portfolio
like to have a good portfolio you want a
lot of diversification in the portfolio
you know if you were going to have a a
portfolio that's 100% AI companies in
the year
2021 then or in the year 2023 or
whatever it is like you're so heavily
indexed just what happens to AI in that
vintage um that you know you don't
really control what happens as much as
the macro environment uh and so like for
us we think a lot about portfolio
management uh and so that means you want
some companies there's like Max risk
really swinging for the fences you want
some companies that are like relatively
straightforward it's a software company
that's already working and maybe the
market is capped but like we're high
confidence that it will get to some
level and so we we construct both our
portfolio and our team with this kind of
similar lens of trying to have a very
diverse collection of people and so we
all have really different investment
Styles interest I am on I'm one of the
people on the furthest extreme is not
the furthest extreme of like I'm kind of
a swing for the fences investor and and
the way I do that is I like
to I'm there's there's like two pieces
to it one is I I just try to study all
the markets in the world like all the
large markets if there's a market that
that has more than 100 Milli hundred
billion dollars worth of revenue flowing
in it like I want to know that market I
want to understand that market um and
just like already have a prepared mind
on how it works so I kind of I hold the
markets in one side of my brain and then
the other side I'm I'm always looking
for changes in the world you know like
what are the why now so like maybe
there's some new regulation that just
got passed or maybe there was just some
major like you know major failure
somewhere or you know you have
decoupling of you know China
manufacturing and US manufacturing or
I'm just always looking for kind of the
intersection of really large markets
that have already thought about a bunch
and then some some new wine now whether
it's a new technology or regulation or
whatever and kind of that intersection
is I think when you get the biggest
opportunities like that's when you have
the swing for the fences opportunities
where you really
you might have the first time ever
credible path to go you know create a
space internet constellation or uh or
like last night I had dinner with one of
my Founders Ali Ian javaheri from node
KN n o WD this is a chemicals
Marketplace most people don't know
anything about the chemicals industry
I'm obsessed with the chemicals industry
it's there's five trillion dollar a year
of chemical sold you know that's about
five times bigger than pharmaceutical
industry you know it's bigger than oil
and gas but no one knows about this
industry it's just kind of like goes
over people's heads and so I had studied
that industry for like 15 years just out
of curiosity and then when I met this
brilliant founder that had this kind of
crazy insight and he was coming from the
industry I I had enough of Beed mind to
realize that that might actually work
and that might actually let you go kind
of become a large uh player in this
gigantic industry so that's that's how I
think about it when you meet these
Founders uh whether it's this founder
you're talking about with the chemicals
Marketplace or or others what are the
traits of great Founders right you know
it's interesting because you've been
doing this for a while now SEO has
obvious been doing this for decades and
probably has a bunch of institutional
knowledge of just like higher
probability of successful founder lower
probability what are some of the things
that you all are looking for or try to
tease out when you meet
Founders number one is probably grit so
it's people that are just never gonna
give up every single startup is hard and
has major like trauma that happens and
you know if you find a Founder that will
never give up there like if if if on
average every startup has four major
trauma moments if you find a Founder
that will never give up compared to a
Founder who's like
50% likely to give up at any one of
those four traumatic moments then it's
like 16 to1 more likely that the gritty
founder succeed simply because they
didn't never give up you know
problemistic so I just I think that's
number one is the grit and you know one
there's a lot of things that can signal
grit in someone's
background immigrants are oftentimes
have more grit you know it takes a lot
to pick up wherever you are and like go
take a risk leave your family and and go
start somewhere new um you know people
that have had trauma in their lives
oftentimes have more grit but it's
something that's really important and so
number two is speed um
and it's and it's really not it's not
even about like IQ it's about um it's
about just like email response time it's
about you know time to take a risk you
know just like ship a new product
feature and see what happens to me Elon
is probably the best in the world at
speed it's part it's one of his many
advantages and he's he's willing to like
test products in in public and sometimes
it works sometimes it doesn't but gets
that data incredibly fast and then can
kind of move on number three I would say
is and this is not going to be popular
but this is like I'd say Street smarts
or judgment they're kind of the same
thing to me um like I'd much rather work
with a Founder that has incredible
judgment just it kind of always gets the
right answer rather than someone who you
know has really high IQ and just kind of
is really book smart I think I think
Street smarts are more important in
business than than book smarts how do
you tease that out right so I think that
makes sense and you know you kind of
look at it as hey I'm betting on this
person everything's going to change
around them they're going to have to
really make good decisions to get us
where we need to go but when you are
meeting with someone even if you meet
with them you know four five six seven
10 times before you invest how do you
decide whether someone's a good decision
maker or
not um amazing
question it's just kind of an art form
it's kind of a skill like I think I'm
I'm not perfect at it I think I'm better
than most at assessing other people's
judgment uh but I do have tricks for how
I do it like like probably the biggest
one
is I I rarely invest in people that I've
only known for call less than a month I
like to know people for at least three
months and really watch them operate a
little bit like watch see if they do
what they say they're going to do see if
they kind of chose the right strategy as
the small number of kind of problems
arise you usually don't have like a
major problem in those three months but
Small Things arise and you see how they
react to it see like what decisions they
make there um and so look I I think
simultaneously if I'm being honest I
think I'm just better naturally at
assessing judgment and I get that from
my mom um but then the other part is is
just kind of watching
people and so as you begin to work with
these people right
um what do you see them doing in terms
of Building Company culture that kind of
sets it apart right so we talk a little
bit about Elon and just its speed if you
read uh Walter ison's new book about
them like I mean there's some crazy
stuff that they're doing there right
literally just like the surges and and
getting people uh to believe in this big
mission what are some of the things that
you all have seen in your portfolio
companies where you know you've already
made the investment you already kind of
believe in the founder but you begin to
have a deeper conviction like this was a
good bet and we can see the early signs
that this company's going to be one of
the companies that break breaks out uh
judgment is certainly one of them which
you like companies are faced with
Crucible decisions all the time you know
not that many but call it one or two a
year a lot of times there's different
magnitudes of of Crucible
decisions and you know it can be like
someone gives you an acquisition offer
do you decide to take it or not it can
be you know your business you know your
business is we had a plan and it's going
pretty well but then it something
happens and and it's kind of like not
working anymore and you should probably
pivot your business a little bit not
like a big pivot but change like the
pricing or you know maybe a new
competitor enters and they're they have
a free product and and like they now
like it kills your top of funnel of new
customers and you have to make a change
there and so I would just say you can
just tell an incredible amount from how
Founders respond to these early kind of
like strategic
decisions um another thing that's funny
is a lot of the best
Founders there's like a balance the best
Founders you don't want to be to first
principal syncing you don't want to
reinvent absolutely
everything
um but the best Founders do reinvent
some things like there there are some
things where they're really stubborn and
they'll just do something you know Steve
Jobs or Elon obviously there's certain
things where they're just like so dead
set on some they have some Vision or
they just they believe something to be
true and a lot of the best Founders just
have that stubbornness but then they
have to be willing to change their mind
when they get data showing that the
original kind of vision was wrong and so
uh for myself one of the things I do
with the donors I work with is I try to
explain how confident I am in any given
advice like I think that you know people
ask me for feedback on stuff all the
time and usually I don't know anything
about it and it's like sure I'll give
you my opinion but like don't take my
opinion seriously you do you you know
it's your business you know more but for
every company I with there's probably
like one or two things a year where it's
like I have extremely strong opinion
like I have been through exactly this
two or three times before and you know
and it's it's often times non obvious
things but like you need to hire your
first sales rep right now because you
are getting product Market fit right now
you don't realize it yet and you your
plan was to hire your first sales rep in
six months but like you need to hire
them right now or her because it's going
to take them a couple months to get
ramped and and like you want to be able
to service that demand when it comes in
and it's it's all levels of this but
there's only two or three times a year
like or sorry one or two times a year
per company where like I actually have a
strong opinion for them and I try to
make it clear when it's a strong opinion
versus like pulling stuff out of thin
air people always laugh um I say all the
time whenever giving advice uh free
unsolicited advice just remember you
know you kind of get what you pay for
and so you know here's my advice and and
uh uh one gets a good laugh but also uh
to just you know don't put too much
weight on it uh because I do think that
it it's hard to remember like somebody
else has all the information right like
they were in the room they saw the eyebr
raise they they got the sense of same
when you were talking about driving
through Afghanistan there's no cars on
the road it's hard to describe to
someone but like you just know
something's up um so that makes sense
the the last thing uh I wanted to ask uh
Before I Let You Go
is seoa given that you have so many
partners such diverse um kind of uh
backgrounds and strategies and all this
stuff how do you guys make
decisions good question P you're you're
a smart guy
um one of the things about sequa there's
a meta Point here which is we're always
evolving you know like
Sequoia part of how we've stayed such a
successful firm is we're just NE we're
super paranoid we're never complacent
we're always willing to take
risk like we view that if we're not
willing to change or take risks then
then like you know we're just going to
lose and so as crazy as it sounds like
even the decision
making changes a lot like I've been only
been at squ for four and a half years
but I've seen the decision making change
kind of meaningfully at at different
points um but I would say some of the
like the core principles are one
we we really try to have like Ultra
direct honest conversations like there's
no sacred cows there's no
egos uh you should not take anything
personally if someone thinks your
company or a company is not working or
is a bad investment whatever like
you you kind of initially when I joined
like I took it very personally but then
you over time you kind of learned that
no really this is uh like feedback is
love it's this is like really just
radically Direct discussion so I'd say
that's point one point two is we really
try to change who has an important voice
based on what the conversation is so
like if it's a hardware company my voice
is pretty important you know if it's a
fintech
company or payments company ruloff's
voice is very important he was the you
know CFO at PayPal and on the boards you
know on the board of block for example
you know or if it's a like an operations
business Alfred's voice is incredibly
important you know he he was the COO at
[Music]
zaposlitev there's times where it's like
the 23-year-old analyst who actually
knows the most about something and we
need to actually be able to elevate them
and listen to them and then the the last
thing I would say is everyone has veto
ability over every investment um it's
kind of crazy and one of the things that
that leads to is it means um there's
like a few aspects of it one is it
forces us to make like you know to have
really intense conv Sation and and uh
and it kind of gives people the ability
to to block things if they if they truly
don't think it's a good investment but
it also means like once we make an
investment if EV if we if we make an
investment it means that everyone wave
their VTO which means that now it is a
team investment like there's no looking
back in three years and saying that oh
man like Shawn made that stupid
investment what a like we should
fire Shawn you know it's it's it's kind
of the opposite it's like no you didn't
veto it uh sea made the investment he's
he is a but you didn't veto it so
you're a too H and so it's not
that we should fire Sean it's it and
maybe maybe they should but it's it's
just like this is a team investment
let's figure out how to make the most of
it let's work together let's not
relitigate the past and so I think
that's the kind of the really important
non-obvious part of having
veto and I guess this a follow up to
this
like there's a social Dynamic obviously
at play and there's also this like you
know whose voice is more important um
how do you use maybe check size to also
signal confidence right or is it
something where hey we want to put you
know the same check size into every
single seed company and and if we can do
that then that's like better for
portfolio
construction we do have some like we we
definitely have some guidelines of what
we aim for and what are like the normal
strike zones for different type of
companies
um and we do have different decision
makers so like seoa is structured we
have an early team and a growth team the
early team is primarily seden a the
growth team is you know
primarily call it $25 million
Investments and up um and so so it's
it's literally a different set of
decision makers in in reality there's
actually a lot of cross flow you know
like there's a lot of people from the
growth team that sponsor Investments for
the early team or or vice versa you know
like I'm on the early team but I let our
SpaceX investment which you know is one
of if not the biggest investment it's
one of it's one of the two biggest
investments in the history of like
sequa us and Europe and so there really
is like a lot of this back and forth uh
and we just it's very fluid like we at
sequ we really try to stay we have
guidelines but we simultaneously try to
stay very fluid so that we can make good
decisions that um that makes sense where
can we send people to find you on the
internet uh well my my Twitter's pretty
spicy right now so you can send them to
my Twitter you know seanm Maguire
or or you can you know my email is s
Maguire SEO cap.com it's and it's on the
website and I think those are my two
residents and when I say Twitter I
should have said X you know apologies X
team
uh you know still still getting my head
around it I I laugh every time I read a
mainstream uh uh media article and
they're like you know X formerly known
as Twitter like they they're they're
gonna do that for like three years so uh
you're you're perfectly fine I think
they might do forever you know who
knows no it's possible um I appreciate
take time to do this uh I learned a ton
I think a lot of people other uh we'll
find this very interesting as well so
we'll definitely have to do it again in
the future PP you are Legend I
appreciate you thank you for having me